the other day i saw a
oh
physic
psychic
psychic
yeah
how was that how much was it though
first of all huh it was 80. i had a
coupon it was actually 68.
no did you use a groupon on to a psychic
no this was just a uh any psyche that's
giving out coupons i'd be a little
warmed about it was 15 off good deal so
what'd she say what's your review
did you make no stuff
she was talking mostly about dating
[Music]
she had some like actually a lot of
geographical type of stuff where she
thought like
plate shifting that sort of stuff stuff
that's out of my control she said
plate shifting like uh tectonics so you
went to a jeep a geologist psychic
dude
what does that have to do with
what's going on with you she was yeah
yeah so the plates and that means you're
also going to meet a girl yeah it sounds
pretty general yeah yeah
if you guys are done being mean i'll
talk to somebody that cares about you
is that the 15
part she's talking about the geology
talked about your dating life a little
bit yes you talked about dating just
about love future she calls them is it
recording are we recording now yeah man
we all okay she does because i just want
to let you know i've been getting
messages about
like you
like like playboy bunnies are hitting me
up but i know they don't want to talk to
me
who the hell's little butterfly
i don't know i feel like she was a
blonde with big boobs so she said little
butterfly says hello
i get messages
you're supposed to be like i don't know
what they want from me and you're
supposed to be the middle man into
theo's heart yeah like i'm your message
i can't tell you that deal
little butterfly huh yeah i'm not saying
her name i i don't i don't remember she
that's her alias like huh like you know
what you should do steve what you should
be is like you know what you should do
is you should
i know what theo likes so
you should do it with me first yeah this
is what road managers do on the road
with the big bands like to get together
yeah so i mean i need to coastline you
need to go you're like the gateway
wiener
i can't wait wiener i can't complain
doesn't buy any cars without me test
driving it and then put a winky face i
also had trouble say
they really want to date you so i've had
like extensive messages like steve like
i'm like supposed to help like i'm like
their coat like how how are we gonna do
this steve can you help me with theo and
i'm like what do you want from you maybe
you could be a life coach
steve the love guru yeah hey
i don't know what to tell you you know
what this tells me if the top of the
morning steve i'm sorry if theo goes to
jail he's still gonna get a lot of he's
gonna be like one of those oh he's gonna
be like your nightstalker yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah chick's gonna be going to jail
to visit him for a conjugal visit and
yeah oh yeah they love you dude you're
gonna do well they love when you
eventually go to prison you're gonna do
well
hey you know how last week you're like
who's gonna go into this
youtube you know
you know how last week you're like who's
gonna go in the military well this week
it's who's gonna go to prison you win
this week no no
statistically i think half of erin
okay
dude that's just the way the tectonic
plates crumble bro
[Music]